how the song the pit
did not become the anthem during covid
is
a really missed opportunity
you were disappeared
do you know what's here's the hilarious
thing about this song
he goes laughs do we all feel in it the
pain
you know it's that's the song it's
actually paradise city it's the chord
progression of paradise city yeah that
drum fill is just paradise city it's
like oh it goes into it yeah we
practiced that song a million times we
played it a million times
do you remember that we went to that
studio to practice it and then we played
it live
in the shoot it was actually really fun
i'd never
i you know played guitar just
recreationally for fun
uh
i guess did i say recreationally and fun
i think it's a little redundant um i
played guitar not professionally
and then we got to do a band practice
and we became a band and we had band
practice we rehearsed and we got to play
a live party we got to play that stuff
live and then we got to play the rapper
live
it was cool we beat mouse rap became a
real thing and it was really cool mike
shore
made me join the band because he was
like you were in a you were in a punk
rock band when you were a kid right so i
i played a band when i was like 17 and
he's like it'll be really funny if
you're just you're just gonna be in this
one episode like you'll just be in this
one episode like you'll play in the
background you'll be you'll come to set
this one time and then pratt will sing
or whatever it's easy and then of course
mouse right is in 15 episodes so it's
like you gotta keep going to set keep
learning the songs but pratt's right
like the thing that was fun about it is
we would actually learn the songs and
then we would play them at the wrap
party every year whatever five mouse red
songs we learned that year we would play
at the rap yeah so that was essentially
all pretty much the same song
145
yeah um and we're gonna have an album
out now did you know about that i saw
that yeah i saw that did you record that
you recorded it while we were doing the
show i guess yeah
it's mouse wrap the awesome albums it's
all the songs that we did on parks and
rec no one consulted me about it they're
like no hey do you want to promote this
album i was like what there's an album
and then they were like yeah you want it
from earth and part of me is like
yeah that'd be cool i'd love i've always
wanted to have to be like that actor who
has the van or the album you know i hope
it gets a million copies and i get the
the [ __ ]
the platinum album on my wall
but then on the other hand i'm like but
you're not gonna like i don't know i
don't think i'm being compensated for
this beyond that whatever
fifteen thousand dollars an episode i
was making for the chat what's up yeah
me neither like uh i think no i think
i'm gonna say no a heart bats on
promoting your album your album they
didn't tell anybody they i don't think
they told mike i don't know i don't know
if they just came out
like wait what i was like i'm in mouse
around i didn't know about that
i just hope that mark rivers gets uh
compensated because that dude is is the
heart and soul and brains and talents
behind mouse wrath so if anything i
would just advocate that mark be taken
care of because he did such a great job
absolutely mark rivers was the drummer
in mouse red and he wrote pretty much
all the songs and i think he recorded a
lot of the tracks and he records a
scratch crack and then you know chris
would sing the actual vocals but yeah
yeah he's a he's a really funny guy and
he's a great musician and he wrote all
these songs really complicated as we
said gcd type songs but they are they
are pitch perfect for what it is right
they're pitch perfect and in fact
if you go into the lyrics of the songs
which i think he would get credit for
writing for the most part uh
they're brilliant pieces of comedic
writing i mean yep i think there's one
song i don't know if it was a mark river
song well one song is called two birds
holding hands
and it says
two birds holding hands so much better
than one
and it's like
the idea that birds are holding hands
and then it's thing like we could fly
through the ocean
really good bad
lyrics
and of course every song includes the
lyrics spread your wings and fly so
that's spread your wings and flies in
every chorus it's in every you know
that's just good writing